good morning believe nation today's
message is believed over to you Fred
Smith the reason I never lost confidence
is because I never believed that the
consequences of losing were were as bad
as some other people might have thought
you know oh my goodness I've lost my
money or what have you I mean I just
wasn't motivated along those lines and I
was very very very sure that what we
were doing was extremely important and
was destined to be successful so that's
the definition I think of an insane
person or a zealous and most
entrepreneurs I think you would find
have that sort of green wire laid in
there just a little bit crosswise and
they begin to get focused on something
and they they believe in the idea or
themselves far beyond what they probably
should so this is obviously a message
that I resonate very well with I think
what gives you the confidence to believe
no matter what in your idea is knowing
that it's it's helpful I think for me I
have lofty and ambitious goals that some
people might think are crazy I want to
help a billion entrepreneurs you know or
billion people even entrepreneurs you
know I want to hit a million subscribers
on my youtube channel and it may not
always happen as fast as quickly as I
want it to be but it's going to happen
and it comes from me knowing that the
stuff that I'm making is valuable to me
as a starting point like I want to make
things that I love
I want to make top 10 videos I want to
write books I want to help brands I want
to create products that I love that I
use that when I look at it makes me
happy and makes me feel good it
motivates me and
somewhere deep down I just know that if
I love it if it makes me come alive then
others will too and I want to share it
and I've told the story a couple times
on the channel but when I was making my
first believe video this is the origin
of the little man's story it was six
minutes long and I was so happy with it
and it was so excited by it and I showed
it to somebody who was in my circle of
friends who was an expert of what he did
in the video space and he said that it's
too long and then we was ever gonna like
this he shouldn't release this and that
was a little soul-crushing but I thought
you know what screw him the idea for
little man came from him because there's
always gonna be people who hate on your
idea I released it because I loved it
because it felt right because when I
watched it it made me come alive and
that's that's the only criteria that I
need if I like it if I love it if it
moves me if I get emotional handling my
product or watching my video that I know
I've done a good job and I don't care
what anybody else thinks I'm gonna put
it out there and it's gonna be
successful and that continues to be the
biggest barometer I chase new projects
because I'm curious about it and I want
to create something that I personally am
proud of that I want to be able to show
my kids my grandkids and the fact that
you guys like it and consume it and
enjoy it and want to be a part of it is
a huge honor I think you need to find
that thing and be so proud of the
products that you create that you don't
care about what other people think about
it you are your own barometer and I
think too many people just mail it in
you do an okay enough project you're not
really except or excited about it you
just get the job done and that can
contribute to you not believing in
yourself and your not having confidence
because you know you're producing
substandard work when you create amazing
things that make you come alive then
it's easy to believe in yourself and
what you can do question today today is
I'm curious what you believe in as a
business what's the mission that you're
on and what are you trying to do to make
the world a better place leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join in this
guy
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso